- So Quentin, obviously
you play one of the dancers
in our show.
- Yes, yes. I play Otis.
- [Kumail] What was it like
for you filming the routines?
I mean, that you worked so hard for 'em.
- Yeah, yeah.
No, I mean, it was tough, obviously.
Like, I have no dance background.
So I had to do two months of choreography,
two months of dance training
before we even started.
Five days a week, hours every day.
So, yeah.
- And people don't know this,
you were so buff coming into the show
that we had to ask you
to stop working out.
- [Quentin] Yes.
- 'Cause you were making
all those guys look bad.
- So I thought, you
know, the first iteration
had the guys from Venice
Beach, these bodybuilders.
So when I got it, I just started lifting.
Got the biggest I'd ever been.
I got this call from Nora and she's like,
"Hey, we saw the tape you sent in.
Thank you so much. Could you
please never work out again?"
(Kumail laughing)
And so, yeah, yeah.
I had to drop about 20 pounds
before we actually
started filming and then-
- [Annaleigh] Of muscle. Of muscle.
- [Quentin] Yeah, of muscle-
- [Annaleigh] Had to
drop 20 pounds of muscle.
- [Murray] Yeah. Yeah.
(audience wooing)
- And him minus 20 pounds of
muscle still looks amazing.
- Yeah.
- [Kumail] You looks so good on the show.
- Thank you. Thank you.
- Really-
- [Audience Member] Take it off!
(Murray and Annaleigh laughing)
- This isn't actually the Chippendales.
- They said take, "Take it off."
- Tune into Hulu. You can
see me take it all off.
- Yeah, go to Hulu. You can watch it now.
All your dreams will come true.
- Actually, it feels weird
seeing you in clothes.
(Murray and Annaleigh laughing)
I'm kidding.
- So that's what he looks like.